one great session we want to recommend
to you is focusing on the unusual
intersection between
quantum computing and arts
so the question is how does an artist
tap
into this fantastically complex topic
let me ask this to the artist herself
i'm online connected to
libby heeney she is the artist and she
is also
a physicist from london hi good morning
nice meeting you
morning libby for someone like you
quantum technology must be a treasure
trove
um what aspect about the topic inspires
you most
well quantum physics really presents a
world that's
quite alien to us it proports
like objects don't have their own
identity anymore
and things can be entangled so they sort
of join together in this
interconnectedness
so for me as an artist it's kind of
trying to tease out these sort of alien
features of quantum physics using
quantum computers
well for non-physicists this is a topic
which is really
difficult to understand what is your
strategy
to engage public audience
so i guess what i'm trying to do is not
necessarily
communicate the science as such but to
create
visual experiences that are intriguing
and
and look entirely different to anything
that couldn't be created
on a quantum computer so
so people might not necessarily need to
understand all the details
but they feel them may get this
intuition through visual means
and what route are you taking uh with
your event at the berlin science week
what can we expect
oh so i i have a background in quantum
computing
so i did a phd in the field before i
retrained as an artist
so first of all i explain a little bit
about what quantum computing
is and then i look at what quantum
computing is critically
so who empowers who it disempowers in
the future when
quantum computers are more fully
developed so i'm really interested in
sort of thinking kind of generally about
how
quantum computers will be in the world
as well as the aesthetic side and
questions about truth and subjective
experience
okay that sounds really exciting tell me
how did you
how did you why did you decide to go
into arts
after you know having having done
quantum
physics yeah so i was always like really
keen to go into arts but when i guess
when i was
um at school as teachers would they were
like
you should do quantum you should do
physics at university
so on and then but i was always making
art and
um trying to express myself visually
and so at some point it just felt very
natural to to make the shift
and also in it when i was working in the
field of quantum computing
i realized that there's very little
ethical
or any sort of social discussion around
the future impacts from a social
perspective a political
perspective um without instrumentalizing
art it really what it does allow me to
do is talk about these ideas from a much
wider perspective and i think that's
really important
so we're looking forward to experience
your art during the berlin science
summit thank you so much libbini for
this interview